So I really hope you enjoyed all this, and the reason is
I really want you to do a program basic statistics by yourself.
So, for the rest of your life, you know how to program it.
When you know how to program it, you know how to do it,
and it will empower you to solve basic problems in probability.
I should tell you in my own life, I've built a lot of robots, and I've applied Bayes rule like crazy.
My job talk at Stanford was all about Bayes' rule applied to robotics.
It's a very powerful paradigm and I hope you enjoyed it.
If you want to dive deeper, there's always Udacity CS373,
which talks about programming and about half of the classes variations of Baye's rule.
I'll spare you with the details here because it's a basic introduction class,
but stay tuned for the next unit, I have another great surprise in store for you.